I think you're gonna get Rowdy tonight
with the ultimate women of wrestling
take over the House of Blues here to
tell us more is the uww general manager
Jenny Santana and pro wrestling's Wonder
Woman it is Santana garage welcome
ladies thank you so much oh my gosh it's
great to have you on the show for the
first time and it's great to have you
back yes it's so great to be back so we
are so excited to be at the House of
Blues this is the first time there's a
wrestling show at House of Blues yeah so
that is super exciting and then we're
just bringing the heat we also have a
toy drive going on so please come out
bring a toy and if you bring a toy you
get entered into a drawing to win a
suite to watch the event from tonight
watch the event tonight so let's talk
about some of the matches today because
you brought some of the championship
titles with you which one do we have
here so we have the Nevada state
champion and then we also have the
United States Champion so we'll be
fighting for this one yeah two nights
you're fighting for that one yeah this
is like the Universe telling you that
tonight Santana is your night it's
already in my hand
[Applause]
how many years in the professional
wrestling business 15 years 15 years
what's it like for you tonight to be
wrestling in Las Vegas all ladies what
does that mean to you I'm super excited
this is um an incredible experience some
of the best of the best women from all
over the world are gonna be right here
in Las Vegas at the House of Blues so if
you guys can make it bell times 7 30 p.m
it's gonna be a blast tonight and and
Jenny you kind of have wrestling in your
DNA with your father is Tito Santana
what is it like being the general
manager of all these ladies it's amazing
because there's so much talent and you
get to see Talent from like Santana said
she's been wrestling 15 years and then
we have girls who've come in who are
wrestling one year or two years and it's
just wonderful to have girls learning
from girls women just empowering women
they're all very positive and we just
want to you know make everyone feel at
home and it's a great environment
they're such great athletes and to have
them all Under One Roof it's just an
amazing opportunity for us and we can
meet the ladies tonight what time does
that start yeah the meet and greet
starts at five o'clock at House of Blues
check it out you can still get your
tickets if you haven't yet they start at
24.99 so please check it out and and Jen
you're a Vegas girl live here in Las
Vegas and you're a teacher what is what
did your and your former life what was
the no in my current life too um I am a
magnet coordinator for Rancho High
School it's an opportunity for kids in
high school to do things that they love
and so our programs are medical and
Aviation so for sure they can still
apply for next year so check it out
magnet.ccs
Caitlyn over there she had you uh she
had a cross paths over there so yes
it's so awesome tonight is going to be a
blast you're going to have control over
everything No One's Gonna Get out of
line with you running the show tonight
definitely no one's getting out of line
yes I haven't been in professional
wrestling that long but I have been in
martial arts for a very long time
through the muscle tonight I love it and
Santana I see it in your future that is
going to be around your waist when the
night is over send me all the Good Vibes
I'm saying can I hold the Nevada yeah
I'm in heaven right now ladies we're
gonna get mixed with that thank you so
much the event is tonight at the House
of Blues all right let's get ready to uh
check out some I look so cool with this
we're gonna check out some Glam Rock we
take a look at Motley Crue's Vegas
Connections in Sin City Chronicles and
in since